A
CAMPAIGN EVENT, ALSO A GANG
SHOOTING IN FRONT OF
LEE ZELDIN'S LONG ISLAND HOME.
SO GOVERNOR HOCHUL, OPEN YOUR
EYES, TAKE OFF YOUR TINFOIL HAT
AND LOOK IN THE SUBWAYS OF
NEW YORK AND SEE FOR YOURSELF.
IF IT'S SO SAFE, YOU WON'T NEED
YOUR SECURITY WITH YOU.
SHE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT CRIME,
ONLY ABOUT HERSELF AND HER
ADHERENCE TO THE INSANITY OF
DEFUND, DISMANTLE, AND
NEW YORK'S INSANE NOBEL LAWS.
JOINING US IS NEW YORK
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE RESULTED
IN THE LONG WITH
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS, WHO HAS
BEEN OUT CAMPAIGNING.
FIRST FOR YOU,
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS, YOU MIGHT
BE HURTING YOUR GREAT STATE OF
FLORIDA BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
MIGRATION TO FLORIDA HAS BEEN
COMING FROM NEW YORK.
AND IF LEE ZELDIN DID A GOOD JOB
AS GOVERNOR, I'M THINKING THAT
MIGHT KEEP PEOPLE IN NEW YORK
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE BAD FOR
THE PEOPLE OF FLORIDA, LESS
INCOME FOR YOUR STATE.
ARE YOU SURE YOU WANT TO SUPPORT
THIS GUY?
>> Gov. DeSantis: WELL SEAN,
HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE MOVE FROM
NEW YORK AND THERE ARE SO
FRUSTRATED WITH THE POOR
GOVERNMENT SO THERE.
FLORIDA IS GREAT, WERE A GREAT
SPOT FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
BUT I WANT ALL ESTATES TO DO
WELL.
THE EFFECT OF THE MATTER IS,
FROM CRIME TO FISCAL
MISMANAGEMENT TO COVERT
RESTRICTIONS, NEW YORKERS GOT IT
WRONG.
LEE ZELDIN WILL GET IT RIGHT.
I THINK THEY'LL BE BETTER FOR
OUR COUNTRY IF HE IS ELECTED
GOVERNOR.
>> Hannity: AND A FIN ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL WITH THEM, UP IN
LAWTON ISLAND, MINNICK OF THE
WOODS THIS PAST WEEKEND.
LEE ZELDIN, A LITTLE OF THOSE
ARE PEOPLE BEHIND YOU BECAUSE I
DON'T SEE FACES ONLY SCIENCE.
ALL THEIR EGO, REAL FACES THERE.
I SPOKE TO YOU WHEN YOU FIRST
GOT INTO THIS RACE AND YOU ASKED
ME WHAT I THOUGHT.
I SAID IT'S POSSIBLE BUT
PROBABLY REALLY DIFFICULT.
HERE YOU ARE NOT ON THE
PRECIPICE.
YOU'RE LEADING IN THIS POOL,
IT'S A VERY TERRORIST.
IT'S THE BLUEST OF BLUE STATES.
WILL YOU SHOCKED THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY THE ONE FROM TONIGHT?
>> Zeldin: WE DEFINITELY WILL
SEAN.
WERE RIGHT HERE IN STATEN ISLAND
RIGHT NOW, GREAT CROWDS HERE.
WHEN GOVERNOR DeSANTIS CAME
UP, IT WAS ON 24 HOURS NOTICE.
WE HAVE MORE THAN 7,000 RSVPS,
IT WAS AMAZING.
WE'RE GRATEFUL HE DECIDED TO
COME UP.
WE HAVE ALL THE MOMENTUM AND
ENERGY ON HER SIDE, AS WELL AS
THE ISSUES.
PEOPLE ARE DONE WITH KATHY
HOCHUL, THIS IS REPUBLICANS,
DEMOCRATS, AND INDEPENDENCE
COMING ALTOGETHER AS NEW YORKERS
TO SAVE THE STATE.
WE STUCK WITH THE ISSUES, WE
WENT SECURITY STREETS, WE WANT
TO MAKE LIFE IN NEW YORK MORE
AFFORDABLE AND PROTECT FREEDOM,
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF OUR KIDS
EDUCATION.
KATHY HOCHUL HAS BEEN TRYING TO
FOLLOW DISTRACTIONS AND TELL
PEOPLE THERE'S NOTHING TO SEE
HERE, NO CRIME GOING ON.
WHEN I'M TRYING TO TALK ABOUT IS
LOCKING UP CRIMINALS.
WE JUST GOT TO KEEP WORKING
HARD.
EVERYONE NEEDS TO GET OUT AND
VOTE.
>> Hannity: OBVIOUSLY SHE'S
NOT LOOKING AT THE STATISTICS.
WHEN YOU COMPARE NEW YORK AND
FLORIDA, YOU HAVE AN AMAZING
STATISTIC.
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS, THE
POPULATION OF FLORIDA NO SIREN
THEN NEW YORK BUT YOU WORK WITH
HALF THE BUDGET OF
NEW YORK STATE.
NOT ONLY HAVE THE BUDGET, YOU
DON'T HAVE A STATE INCOME TAX IN
NEW YORK IT'S 10% HOWEVER.
IF YOU LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY
IT'S ANOTHER 3.5%.
IF YOU ADD THAT TO THE FEDERAL
INCOME TAX, THAT'S $0.53 OUT OF
EVERY DOLLAR YOU'RE GIVING THE
GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S BEFORE
SALES TAXES, HIGH PROPERTY
TAXES, ET CETERA.
HOW DO YOU DO IT WITH SO MUCH
LESS AND LESS TAXES AS WELL IN
FLORIDA?
>> Gov. DeSantis: IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
WHO MOVE FROM THERE, THEY'LL
TELL ME, YOUR ROADS ARE BETTER
HERE, YOUR INFRASTRUCTURE IS
BETTER HERE, YOUR SERVICES ARE
BETTER.
AND WE JUST FINISHED THIRD AND
FOURTH RESPECTIVELY FOR
FOURTH GRADE READING IN MATH, I
THINK NEW YORK WAS IN THE 30s.
IN NEW YORK STATE THERE IS
NOBODY RIGHT NOW WHO IS AN
ADVOCATE FOR THE TAXPAYER.
BASICALLY THE TAXPAYERS ARE
TREATED DOES DISRESPECTFULLY,
THE POLITICIANS GIVE THE MONEY
TO SPECIAL INTERESTS PEOPLE
DON'T LIKE SULLIVAN SULTAN'S
GOVERNOR WILL MEAN THE PEOPLE OF
NEW YORK WILL HAVE SOMEBODY
LOOKING OUT FOR TAXPAYERS FOR A
CHANGE.
WE RESPECT TAXPAYERS IN FLORIDA.
WE WANT NO INCOME TAX OF COURSE,
TAX LIGHTLY, SPENT REASONABLY.
WE MEET THE BIG PRIORITIES BUT
WERE ABSOLUTELY GOING TO RESPECT
THE TAXPAYERS.
LEE WILL DO THAT IN NEW YORK AND
IT WILL MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE
NOT JUST FOR INDIVIDUALS BUT
BUSINESSES.
>> Hannity: NEW YORK IS REALLY
SUFFERING HUNTER BIDEN INFLATION
RATE GAS PRICES ARE NO MORE THAN
$4 A GALLON GOING HIGHER EVERY
DAY.
WE HAVE A REAL IN TERMS OF THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT POPULATION.
THEY'RE MOVING TO NEW YORK IN
BIG NUMBERS ON THAT'S PART OF
THE PROBLEM.
LAW AND ORDER, SAFETY AND
SECURITY FOR PEOPLE, THESE ARE
ISSUES.
NEW YORK IS ALSO DEALING WITH
WOKE EDUCATION VERSUS CLASSICAL
EDUCATION, MORE IN NEW YORK THAN
IN FLORIDA.
WILL YOU BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH
THOSE ISSUES ESPECIALLY IF
YOU'RE DEALING WITH A LIBERAL
LEGISLATURE IN ALBANY?
>> Zeldin: .
WE HAVE TO.
PARENTS HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
TO CONTROL THE UPBRINGING OF
THEIR CHILD.
THEY DON'T RELINQUISH THAT RIGHT
WHEN THEY SAID KIDS TO SCHOOL.
AS GOVERNOR DeSANTIS WAS JUST
POINTING OUT COME OF THE GAPS
ARE ACTUALLY EVEN WIDER WHEN YOU
LOOK AT BLACK STUDENTS, HISPANIC
STUDENTS, AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
YOU LOOK AT THE FOURTH GRADE
READING QUALITY IN NEW YORK AND
FLORIDA, THE DOING BETTER IN
FLORIDA SPENDING TWO AND A HALF
TIMES LESS.
WE HAVE TO MAKE THE DIPLOMA
WORTH MORE.
SOME KIDS WILL GO OFF TO
COLLEGE.
GETTING THEIR HANDS ON
EQUIPMENT, NETWORKING WITH
TRADES, THE TECHNICAL INJURY
PATIENT, PEOPLE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT A DIPLOMA IS THE
KEY TO A GOOD PAYING JOB.
EVERYONE DESERVES ACCESS TO A
QUALITY EDUCATION, REGARDLESS OF
RACE, CLASS, GENDER OR ANYTHING
ELSE.
>> Hannity: YOU HAD PRESIDENT
FROM SUPPORTING YOU,
RON DeSANTIS CAMPAIGNING WITH
YOU.
ARE YOU SURPRISED THAT THIS IS
GARNERED AS MUCH NATIONAL
ATTENTION AS IT HAS IN NEW YORK
AND THAT WHEN THIS BULL CAME OUT
EUROPE IN THIS RACE AND HOW
WINNABLE IT IS?
WHEN YOU BREAK DOWN THE MATH,
YOU HAVE A CITY LIKE NEW YORK
WITH A VERY HIGH CONCENTRATION
OF PEOPLE IN A VERY SMALL
GEOGRAPHIC AREA.
BUT THEN THE REST OF
NEW YORK STATE, LONG ISLAND IS
NOW RED.
UPSTATE NEW YORK IS NOT READ.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC VOTE WILL YOU GET DO
YOU THINK?
WHAT PERCENTAGE DO YOU THINK YOU
NEED TO GET TO WIN?
>> Zeldin: WERE CRACKING INTO
THE LOW 20s NOW AND THAT'S A
GOOD PLACE.
WE CAN GET LESS THAN 30% OR WE
CAN'T WIN.
BUT IF YOU GET MORE THAN 35%,
THAT IT STARTS TO BECOME VERY
DIFFICULT TO LOSE.
I'M SEEING IT ON STATEN ISLAND.
I'M SEEING IT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE VILLAGE.
CHRIS GOT ABOUT 29%.
WERE NOW PULLING IN THE 30s.
SOME OF THE POLLS COMING OUT ARE
SHOWING US IN THE MID-TO-HIGH
30s.
THERE ARE DEMOCRATS WHO FEEL THE
PARTIES GOT TO FOR LEFT.
SOME REGISTERED DEMOCRATS ARE
VOTING FOR THE MOST NORMAL
PERSON IF THERE IS ONE IN THE
PRIMARY.
THERE ARE DEMOCRATS WHO WANT
SAFE STREET AND OPPOSE
CONGESTION PRICING.
THEIR REASON NEW YORKERS ARE
HEADING DOWN TO FLORIDA BECAUSE
THEY SEE THAT
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS RESPECTS
FREEDOM, HE SUPPORTS SAFETY AND
REDUCES TAXES.
HE WELCOMES FAMILIES IN THEIR
ATTEMPT TO FOLLOW THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
THE BAD NEWS FOR
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS IS THAT
HE COULD LOSE HIS BEST
REAL ESTATE AGENT WHO WILL BE
FIRED A WEEK FROM TODAY.
>> Hannity: HE MAY REGRET THIS
DECISION IN THE END, AS I JOKED
BEFORE.
JOE BIDEN WAS DONE CAMPAIGNING
AGAINST YOU IN FLORIDA TODAY AND
I'M SURE THAT REALLY UPSET YOU,
RIGHT?
>> Gov. DeSantis: I THINK IT'S
AN IN-KIND CONTRIBUTION TO MY
CAMPAIGN.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE THE OFFER
PUBLIC.
WILL UNDERWRITE HIM TO STAY IN
FLORIDA FOR THE REST OF THE
CAMPAIGN.
IF JOE WANTS TO STAY, IT'LL BE
ON OUR DIME.
WE LOVE THE PEOPLE OF FLORIDA TO
BE REMINDED THAT THE DEMOCRATS
OF THE STATE ARE WITH BIDEN 100%
OF THE TIME.
>> Hannity: THIS'LL BE A
SHOCKER A WEEK FROM TONIGHT